[Music]
hello everyone
all right so we are going to start our
chapter on stress today
uh and i simply cannot stress it enough
uh one is very much intended here
i simply cannot stress it enough uh how
chapter this
uh how important this chapter on stress
is during that study of mechanical
engineering
and let me be very frank here uh every
time i teach this chapter whether it is
in the context of mechanics
food mechanics or mechanics of solids
i simply cannot help feeling a certain
sense of excitement
as i'm beginning as i begin to start
this chapter
now it's rather unfortunate that we have
to that i have to deliver this lecture
in this kind of recorded fashion because
what happens in a real face-to-face
class is that
when i'm when i'm beginning to uh when i
begin
this chapter i usually ask my students
this question
then let's pause for a moment and try to
think
uh for some time about some possible
uh application within the broad context
of
engineering and perhaps even going
beyond engineering in general physics in
general life
where uh
when you try to think of an application
where
uh stress as you understand from your
previous studies
of mechanics and fluid mechanics the
stress is not important
okay i am not asking you to think of an
application where stress is important
rather i want you to think and try to
find out an application where stress
is not important so uh
since we are not meeting face to face
the best thing that i can
request you is to just to pause this
video for half a minute maybe
just pause this video for half a minute
and uh
and think okay so so i'll wait
pause this video now go for it
so if you have really pause this video
thank you
and i uh i hope you have some answers
but uh to those who didn't pause well
let's go ahead um
so i've tried to think of this answer
and every time i
try to think no matter which which
application
area i think about i simply cannot find
an example where
there is absolutely no uh no
relevance of stress you can think of
huge man-made structures like ships
aircrafts spacecrafts
vehicles are the robust machinery
present inside the vehicles the robust
machinery that is present
in industrial settings uh starting from
those robust machinery come down to very
small applications very household
applications
like uh things like things for domestic
use like tables chairs all mirrors
uh and come down to even smaller things
even more delicate things like uh
like watches uh and not just mechanical
watches mind you
uh even your mobile phone okay the
ubiquitous
uh mobile phone uh the
this very laptop that i'm using uh this
pen tablet that i have beside me
uh anything that you may think about and
certainly your bicycles
uh which are just well
sadly lying in your coastal sheds um
in every every aspect uh you'll find the
application of stress
so as far as mechanical engineering and
mechanics is concerned
this right here is the heart and soul of
mechanical engineering i believe okay
there are a number of other important
things
in in mechanical engineering overall but
uh
as far as the absolute core fundamental
concepts is concerned stress is right
there at the top
okay so this is like the heart and soul
of uh
mechanical engineering all right
so so with this the little uh
quantification so to speak
we will start our chapter of uh stress
uh
now when we do that because it is such
an important thing as i've just
emphasized what we'll do is uh
we will try to start at the very basics
okay now when i say basics
it doesn't mean very necessarily very
simple things
but very fundamental things now when we
do that
perhaps some of you will detect a lot of
similarity with what you have already
studied
in mechanics and fluid mechanics and
that will be true
because you have studied some of those
aspects but there will be some crucial
differences
and uh especially
when contrasted with what you studied
and the way you studied stress
analysis of stress uh in your first year
and how you would
study and approach uh this concept uh
right here in mechanics of solids your
third year level
uh one of the uh one of the most
fundamental differences
will be in the concept of traction
uh across a plane at a point so this
this new word
traction
[Music]
this is where we will start our our
entire discussion
now we will get down to the to the
mathematical representation of it and
down to the nuts and bolts of it uh
but again i want you to
think and this is this is a discussion
which uh i remember having with each of
your
previous uh or each of your senior
batches
uh in the past two three years uh
that the moment i mentioned traction uh
what do you
what what kind of imagery does it bring
to your mind
so i've asked this to seniors and uh
uh in a in a live face-to-face class of
course
and uh it was a very lively discussion
and uh
and the uh and almost always uh
the the some of the students they point
out that
uh this uh this word traction they come
across
uh very commonly uh especially in the
commentary of formula one racing
so suppose there is a little bit of
rainy uh uh
of rain going on and the formula one
cars are
are are riding at very high speeds
on those tracks uh so perhaps the
commentator will say something like
uh whether the or perhaps comment on
something about
how much traction the tires are getting
on those slippery tracks because of the
rain
now there's a lot of interesting things
regarding the traction of formula one
tires
there are different varieties of tiles
and i am sure those of you who are in
team card will
find this particular uh aspect of
discussion fascinating
but in the interest of time let us not
get into that uh
if you want maybe we can can have a have
a separate discussion on it in our
discussion boards or something like that
but maybe not in this recorded lecture
so uh
coming back to the the to the beginning
of the chapter
uh this is where we'll start a fraction
across a plane
at a point okay so we'll actually begin
with the
with the real uh the real discussion as
far as our syllabus demands it
in the next part of the lecture and
again i hope
that you will share the excitement of
this entire chapter with me all frog
thank you very much